نعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى الاستثمار في
القطاعات المتنامية لشركائنا مع
جذبهم للاستثمار والنمو
معنا في قطاع النمو الخاص بنا ، لذلك
فعلنا ذلك مع الولايات المتحدة على مدى عدة
عقود ، استثمرنا في الولايات المتحدة بقدر ما استثمرنا في
الشركات الأمريكية  استثمروا في
المملكة العربية السعودية ، فمن الأساسي
لاستراتيجيتنا مع الصين أن نتبادل الاستثمار
ومن المناسب أن نفعل ذلك هنا لأن
الصناعات البريطانية بحاجة إلى النمو في الخارج
ولا يمكنها النمو هنا فقط الآن
ستكون المملكة العربية السعودية وجهة رائعة
لهم ولكننا نريد  من أجل الاستثمار بشكل انتقائي أيضًا
في المملكة المتحدة حيث توجد
فرصة نمو مربحة ، فإن لندن
في موقع الصدارة بمعنى ما بالنسبة
للاكتتاب العام في أرامكو ، فهي حريصة حقًا على الحصول على
الإدراج هنا ولكن الأهم من ذلك
إظهار المرونة المطلوبة
لشركة تديرها الدولة و  هل يجب
أن يكون لديك شخص غربي يستمع إليه من وجهة نظرك
ليكون ناجحًا جيدًا ،
كما تعلم ، فإن بورصة لندن التي تعرف أنها واحدة من أفضل البورصات
تنظيماً وقد
احترمناها ولديها العديد من الشركات الكبيرة بما في ذلك في
قطاع النفط والغاز
المدرج هنا شركات النفط الوطنية
وكذلك اللجنة الأولمبية الدولية وبالتأكيد منذ
البداية كان موضع نزاع ، فلا
يزال هناك تنافس على
مكان الإدراج الثاني ، الشيء الوحيد الذي
نعرفه اليوم هو أن الوسادة سوف  أن نكون
موقع الإدراج الرئيسي
كبورصة وطنية لدينا ونحن في انتظار تنفيذ
الإصلاحات والانضمام إلى
MSCI وسيكون إدراج أرامكو اليوم
حافزًا لسوق رأس المال هذا
حيث نجلب رأس المال الدولي
إلى المملكة